[Music]
as a developmental psychologist who
studies cognition in children we were
really excited to be able to focus on a
particular aspect of a cognitive bias
which is the development of optimism in
children so we're often studying
cognitive mechanisms and how children
are using these to reason about various
aspects of the world around them
including other people's thoughts and
preferences and we also are looking at
how children are choosing to learn from
other people as well so I'm going to
talk about two lines of research one is
that mostly which I'll talk about
looking at the development of optimism
and children which we were really
grateful to the hope and optimism
initiative to fund so that we could do
that and another that is looking at
outside of children how we're thinking
about society and how children's own
optimism might also apply to groups and
society as well okay so for the purposes
of operationalizing how we were going to
go about studying optimism and we're to
start looking at this and children we
took a working definition that's come
from tal Ichiro who is going to speak
her later as well as others working in
this field thinking about optimum
optimism as a cognitive bias and this is
the bias to overestimate the likelihood
of positive outcomes and to
underestimate the likelihood of negative
outcomes there's been a lot of work on
this adults which Mike already talked
about until he's gonna speak about I'm
not gonna go into detail on it but
typically roughly we see 80% of the
adult population is optimistic so what
about kids I mean our kids optimistic
and the same way as adults do we see
this optimism and buy a bias and what we
have seen in the data that we knew to
date was that kids are very positive
they seem to be very positive about
themselves and interpret expectations
for themselves very positively
especially up to about six years of age
or so but if you ask children and you
ask them to evaluate themselves they
tend to do this really positively so
here's an example of watching a bunch of
kids in a race
and one girls pointed out that she can't
run very fast and another girl over
there has pointed out she can run fast
and a child simply asked which girl are
you more like okay this is the way we
can ask simple questions and get data
out of kids okay and here's a
six-year-old girl a typical answer would
be something like her I'm more like the
fast girl okay and kids will evaluate
these on different scales but they tend
toward optimism
now you might were positive at least
having positive interpretations you can
also look at this in the academic realm
and something that can be evaluated much
more relatively because you can ask for
an adult evaluation of the situation so
here's a child again up to roughly six
or so years of age you ask them how do
you do in school and they say I'm really
good I get mostly A's and I get lots of
stars on my papers but if you ask the
teacher they have a different answer not
a B student sometimes gets a start and
what you see is this escalation in
initially escalation and being positive
and then this starts to become more
realistic the child's own view of
themself comes more in line with reality
so we were asking the question are
children optimist or realists because
all of the previous work didn't really
look at optimism it looked at only about
positivity about self how about applying
these kinds of things to different
likelihoods of expectations out there in
the real world now you might wonder can
maybe can kids even do that what about
if kids can't do the math you can't give
them these complicated math problems
like eight out of 1,000 or three out of
twenty seven people are likely to get
can't you know whatever these things are
and expect them to weigh that in but in
fact babies already by the end of the
first year of life are really good at
doing these kinds of mental statistics
and evaluating likelihood of
probabilities here's one example but
there are many many that I could take
for you this comes from my colleague
phase U at Berkeley who looks at
probabilistic reasoning and babies and
here is a test that was just looking at
whether babies have any expectation
about what sample should come out of
whatever the sample they're presented
with and whether they show surprise or
not given what that is so if you show
them a box full of balls in this case
there's three different color balls and
there's about a third of each and you
choose randomly so you
choose a random sample okay you would
predict as an adult I think that 1/3
roughly of the time you should get each
ball color okay that's not the sample
that came out in this case and so what
you can do is see whether babies are
surprised that that sample was withdrawn
from there or whether they just don't
pay any attention any difference to that
whether the expected sample was come out
and in fact what they do is they're
pretty surprised when the sample doesn't
match the population from which it was
drawn and we have collected data with
158 kids so far from a very wide range
of sample of children in the st. Louis
area where I live these are kids of
different racial and ethnic backgrounds
coming from different economic
populations so one last task I want to
tell you about for this this set is
looking at how children view people who
are optimistic versus pessimistic kids
were much more likely to choose the
optimistic person not just the
optimistic outcome but they wanted to be
friends with the person that had the
positive response and this often
happened even in the face of accuracy so
we're looking at this now too for
learning and who they might rather learn
from an optimistic person or a correct
person and this is something that is
also another field that's had a lot of
attention recently in developmental
psychology that children really like to
learn from in fact like better people
who are reliable so we've looking at how
liking optimism and wanting to learn
from someone who's optimistic has to
reconcile with learning from somebody
who is accurate and realistic in that
sense okay because we do want to make
proper sense of the world okay what I
want you to take home from that though
too is that children already in the
first few years of life do seem to have
a propensity for op the optimistic
viewing of things they tend to be
optimistic and that we might be able to
learn something by seeing that children
are making the same sort of mistakes or
having the same kinds of biases as
adults we might be able to learn
something about the trajectory of this
and get some insight into how we as
adults got the way we are
you